welcome back to on base live I'm Mookie
Betts and today we got another
Diamondback Mr Zach gallon thanks for
coming on here though yeah man thanks
for having me I'm excited you uh
you enjoy Arizona like year round I do I
mean it's tough right now it's a hundred
and bro so
you're going to work right when I go to
work I got a nice little t-shirt on some
shorts flip-flops it just feels
beautiful outside
when you go out here you getting
sunburned immediately immediately like
my I mean I parked my car in the garage
and it's still hot when I get in the car
in the garage so I had like what do you
do you don't go out on the off days like
what do you you can't go outside it's
too hot no I mean some guys will be
brave enough to play golf but like
anything over 110 I'm like nah I'm good
I'll just stay at the house yeah
anything over 110 nah I'm good I'm good
like so like one of five I've done it
during covet but it's mine like we were
like let's just go out and grind it out
but now I'm like pleasure to stay at the
house so what other is everything shut
down like during the summer time right I
mean no stops like the stuff's open so
people just act like it's normal I think
so yeah you just get used to it it's
like it's just dry does it change your
wardrobe like being here uh because you
know where you're from is the complete
opposite yeah I would say I mean
you kind of just get into the flow of
the Season you're wearing shorts and
t-shirt every day unless you're on the
road but it is nice when you're on the
road to like be able to wear like jeans
and like a nice shoes to wear different
things yeah got some Swag yeah all right
so
this year you're 20 you're an All-Star
right and you start the All-Star Game
tell me when you find you're starting
what what went through your head
yeah I was uh I was at my house and Tori
facetimed me and I'm like drinking a cup
of coffee and he's like what are you
doing I'm like just hanging out he's
like all right I'm letting you know
you're gonna start the All-Star game
like I was like what like he he had kind
of prompted me before he was like hey
it's between you and somebody else so
like don't be surprised if it happens so
when he called when he FaceTime him he
never facetimed me so it's got to be
something good so he told me
um and I was just like
I sat on it for like two hours I was
trying to get a hold of my girlfriend
then I wanted to call my parents and
whatnot and it was just like yeah it was
it was crazy it was surreal but I mean
we still did you know a few more games
left to go in the season so I was trying
to lock in for my next start but also
enjoy that at the same time so is there
a balance because I'm thinking in
someone like yourself I can just see
your presence on the mound
it was like a it you were it was cool
I'm starting an All-Star game but it's
also like I I feel like you took it as
you damn right I'm starting All-Star
game I'm balling you know was it like
that did that come did that come across
your mind it seems like it I was I was
trying to do I was trying to do both I
got like for me the honor of starting
the All-Star game was one thing but like
being able to stay in my routine of
starting a game was also huge for me so
like I tried to do both of like all
right I'm enjoying this I'm gonna take
it in I'm gonna soak it all in but at
the same time like yeah it's like
starting a game as much as it's an
exhibition or whatever like I'm starting
this like a legit game yeah okay so
let's switch gears a little bit you said
you said before that you're you're
Frugal you don't spend a whole lot of
money
why is that
I don't know what's funny too is as a
kid like my my parents always joked that
if I got money like for my birthday like
burn a hole in my pocket like I want to
spend it like immediately going broke
wait yeah and then I'm like all right so
like as a kid my parents like instilled
in me like hey if you want something
nice like you're gonna have to spend
your money for it so like then I started
realizing like all right I'm gonna save
up for something nice if I wanna as
opposed to just
um so yeah I'm just kind of like uh I'm
more of a Bargain Hunter if anything
then like a swapping yeah like I would
rather like find a good deal like if I
can find someone on sale that's all me
but like yeah it's kind of a so you used
to go to Goodwill and get like the
letter like the the starter jacket I
wouldn't go to Goodwill but like I was
crushing Marshalls and like TJ Maxx and
whatnot uh I'll introduce you to my mom
because Mom you know how much you love
Marshalls Zach does too oh I'll make
sure you guys get a little half my
closet was Marshall's for the longest
time like but so that's what yeah TJ
Maxx and Marshalls that's what I wore to
school all through High School Nordstrom
Rack I still get jeans from there like
okay so yeah you got nice shoes you got
a nice shoe collection though I've
noticed all the shoes you wear they're
on some nice shoes so
if you got a plug
or use that's where you spend your money
which one is it both I got ISO my buddy
uh natto at undefeated hooks me up
pretty good and then it's every time I
go in there I'm like just he's doing
damage every time yeah so what going in
how much are you like I'm about to spend
because you know you you
being frugal
you got a budget yeah I ain't going over
this budget yeah so what's your budget
what's that gallon shoe budget there's
that's the problem there is no shoe
budget it's like all right if I like it
I'm gonna buy it
um it's usually stuff that comes out he
sends me pictures hey you want this I'm
like yeah I'll I'll take that so it's
like
yes it's it's tough sometimes in there
he's gonna get me twice now and then in
the last like week and a half that's
like oh so you you catch it for free for
the next couple weeks pretty much yeah
yeah you gotta do what you got to do
yeah all right so we got there's a game
called on base off base
you enter you out right I got a couple
of things
you're on base off base with hitting a
bird with the baseball
oh man uh you gotta be on basis that
tell me about that because y'all it's a
diamondback Thing Man Randy did it you
did it are you aiming for the bird I'm
on no no see that's the thing I'm off
base on the the bird the consequences of
like what happened to the bird
um so animal cruelty you're off base I'm
off base let's get that out there it was
it was an unfortunate accident for sure
um but yeah it was crazy like I'm out
there just playing catch but one of our
coaches DC it's just me and him out
there and you can see a couple like
their ground screw guys I think are
right there yep he like whiffs the ball
I'm like I threw a curveball it wasn't
anything like crazy like it's just solid
curveball and he whipped and I'm like
what is going on out here then I see the
bird kind of like just tumbled so you
didn't even see the bird before no
you're just throwing the bird was flying
at like a 45 degree angle to me and just
like I'm like that ball like Ricochet
took a weird hop like I don't know
what's going on and then I'm out there
for like a good 10 seconds going like oh
oh like and nobody's paying attention so
then I came in The Dugout and everyone's
like what's going on like so I think I
hit a bird so they went and got the clip
from like our replay guy I see how did
you did you feel bad was a bird like
limping
there wasn't much limping going off oh
here we go yeah he was out of there yeah
he caught him flush yeah it was it was
not good or was it I don't know I'm not
you didn't want to get close enough to
see him I'm not yeah I'm not like I did
I looked over it but like I'm like maybe
this thing's still alive and it's gonna
come back for Revenge so I kind of just
yeah it was I it was it was a wild
experience at least you didn't hit him
with 95. you know what I'm saying at
least it was a curveball it was a kind
of a smooth that's the thing like I
think if I if I hit him with a fastball
people were like oh he was aiming for
him but like I couldn't aim with a curb
I was just throwing it to where I was
throwing it to and he flew in there I
mean it is what it is yeah he should
have watched where he was flying but
whatever all right so what about
watching
binge watching a TV show and on base or
off base
um I'm I'm on base with that it's like I
feel like if you got a girl you gotta be
in on it yeah and I like most of the
time I'm the one that falls asleep first
so she's like I'm like I gotta catch up
like Ted lasso We Were Watching Ted
lasso you fell asleep I mean I
understand how you could fall asleep on
Ted lasso but that's a great show it's a
great show but like she'd be four four
episodes ahead and I feel bad because
like she'd have to rewatch the same
episode if she's four episodes ahead
that means you went to sleep immediately
oh I'm I got as soon as I can sleep
anywhere like as soon as my head hits
something that's like just semi-soft
gone unless like you know unless it's
something I'm like really locked into
then I'll be the one that like stays up
into like two of them so let me what's
what's the show that you were watching
um that you will stay up for
so right now we just started 1883 that
Yellowstone like the spin-off or
whatever okay yeah I've heard I've heard
that's good I've heard a lot of good
things about Yellowstone
yellow sounds good but like that's
Yellowstone or any like show fall asleep
and I'm like I gotta watch one more like
one more I watch them and then you the
next day I know it's two in the morning
I'm like damn I gotta get up so so
Yellowstone is what keeps Zach gallon's
attention I would say yeah I mean teles
is a great show it's a great show but it
takes you two to three days to watch one
episode yeah it's probably that's
probably about right I'm shaking my head
it's a little it's get slow you know it
does it does Yellowstone you'll see
Yellowstone you'll see like what happens
like it keeps you in on it yeah what
about breakfast meat being called pork
roll and not Taylor ham we asked Mikey
about it Mike Trout for those who don't
know who Mike is and
he had no no idea it made me no I did it
yeah I think I saw that he like didn't
know that it was maybe cam or something
like that he made me question if he
really knew his roots but that's right
because it's not it's poor girl
okay all right so I'm on base like yeah
like that's so there's this Regional
device
learn me the difference because I don't
know what like so you know what I'm
saying because I just know it as a
sausage egg and cheese Big muffin you
know what I'm saying that's that's what
we called it when you but we did you
know I never I don't know what this meat
breakfast whenever you guys play the
Phillies I need you to go I don't know
like in the city where to get but like
you need to get a pork or egg and cheese
and it'll change your life is this
sausage no it's more like
a Hamish kind of
fit like Taylor hams that's that's where
have you ever been a honey baked ham do
they got do they got it there uh yeah I
think so so I can go to you know I go to
Nashville I got I know where Honey Baked
Ham is yeah try it yeah but Taylor ham
is the brand that's the thing oh see
there you go
if you Google Taylor it's Taylor ham
sausage Taylor hand pork roll is what so
if you look at it because it's like
Taylor ham and then on the packaging it
says pork roll so it'd be equivalent to
like Jimmy Dean
it's like no it's a sausage biscuit got
it got it got it okay all right when I
go
I'll make sure I go check out a Taylor
ham yeah poor girl Taylor hand pork
so all right what about
um you're a music guy a pre-game
playlist your playlist but of being like
soft r b or whatever
it's changed now
um it was like just kind of like chill
like just some Oar like crazy like it's
just kind of like a band it's like okay
I don't even really know how to describe
like what they are you're a bad guy not
really I I my taste is like very
I don't want to say it's just widespread
like I listen to a lot of stuff
um it was very like slow kind of just
like because you know you get to the big
leagues and everything so fast and I
need something to slow the heart rate
down and then about halfway through last
show I'm like all right I'm going into
the games like a little too mellow now
so I've kind of switched it up it's a
lot of like Pusha T Lil Wayne Drake so
yeah okay I need something to get the
heart rate going yeah so and what is
your start day you have the music in the
in the weight room I'm assuming correct
no I don't care I I just put my
headphones yeah so like I I've never
been a guy to like
I always kind of hated when guys like
played their music some like I don't
like your music tasting like I gotta you
know so I'm like I'm not gonna put that
burden on anyone I'll just put it in my
headphones and just do my thing so you
don't want to like Flex that muscle a
little bit because you know it's my
start day with listening to my music now
I gotta go y'all gotta go go on
somewhere then now I see that's the
thing I got guys there's no like most of
our guys just put their headphones in so
like so how do y'all talk to each other
then
no I'm saying like if it's your start
day like oh guys okay okay yeah
tomorrow's pitching or whatever like he
just puts his headphones on like okay
perdoma or Walker is the one that
usually does the music they do like
solid job of playing enough like Latin
music like country music rap like
whatever like this is good so I don't
think a lot of guys get too mad about
okay what's going on what about a on
base off base snake skin belt
I gotta be on base about that so like
whose idea did that that kind of come
from like that was that was me so oh
you're the idea behind it yeah tell me
what how it all kind of so uh show Bells
nakona you know they come to the spring
training every year so they brought I
forget if it was 21 or 22 they bought
the samples and they had this snake skin
belt I'm like we're gonna wear these
serpientes uniforms like they're not my
favorite but like might as well do
something with them so last year I was
going to order it
and by the time that the season started
it was midway through I'm like I don't
know how many starts I'm gonna get in
this unit for like I'm gonna wait so I'm
like next spring training I'm gonna
order one so I ordered one
um looks good and it turned out pretty
good the first first night of War I was
like man I bear a pitch ball on this
thing so I could show wearing this Bell
it's not gonna be good no the you know
we're gonna say something about it yeah
so it's worked out pretty well so far do
you wear whatever uniform or just that
just that one yeah and then so long ago
so he's like yeah I'm in on that like
where'd you get them like show belt so I
think he got like a red one he got like
a tier one he just wears a different
belts of different yeah I think I mean I
think he's since he's gotten him I think
he's been on the i o but I would imagine
when he comes back he's gonna he's like
he was wearing he got very similar belt
to that and he was just wearing it like
to the field like just a normal Hotel
yeah he was all in yeah so that's funny
I love it all right so let's switch
gears a little bit bro
and get to some Armfield stuff
last year
you pitch great you came in fifth I
think in cyan boating and
to some people like that's a really good
year they're satisfied
man I did great I did awesome but I feel
like for you you do feel like I did do I
did have a good year I did Pitch well
but
I don't like coming in fifth like you
know and so tell me about tell me kind
of about that and what it was like going
through pitching well and then coming in
because you that lets you know those are
some really good starters out there too
and like where did that what did that
tell you yeah I mean you know like
coming in fifth obviously you want to
come in first you want to win it's like
it's like it's great you get the
recognition that you came in fifth and
and last year's I mean don't get me
wrong Sandy was the unanimous like for
sure you know what I mean so and so were
the other guys I just I felt like
for me it was like all right I kind of
had that second half of just
I don't even like it was just crazy so
for me I just felt like a lot of it more
so was not necessarily good maybe enough
respect just because you know it is on
the west coast sometimes it's like in
like a smaller market like so for me it
was just like and I think what got me
was that
the player like the player vote I came
in the top three and I never expected to
win because I'm like I didn't have a
great first half Sandy ran away he was
right I mean he that's the thing like I
could I could look myself in the mirror
and say that but I'm like okay when the
players voted me top three and I
finished top five I'm kind of like all
right that's not adding up like I I was
my peers like what they give me I'm like
okay so yeah but I mean for me I I'm I'm
never settled it's always like I don't
want to be idle right those reporters
that didn't vote you to get into the top
five like do you did you ever find out
who those people were I so yeah that I
have the
um screenshot you know the poll comes
out and they show you the votes whatever
I screenshotted it and I actually had
one reporter come up and apologize to me
but it was weird the way he started he's
like you got me in your phone I'm like I
don't never met you before in my life
I'm like what's he mean he's like I was
one of those people that didn't Bo free
and I apologize
um and I didn't know how to work I
didn't know how to yeah I didn't know
how to take it I'm like that doesn't do
me any good now it's like when umpire is
like hey man I missed that call yeah
it's too late
yeah I mean there is a
there is some satisfactory like knowing
that hey you messed up but it's too late
I really don't want to hear it yeah from
you you know and so so do you like
because Jalen hurts has that too I think
he had him losing walking off on the
Super Bowl and is that what you use as a
motivation yeah I mean that's not
something I'm necessarily like going
back to like and looking at
um you know it's it's nothing like that
it's more of just I kept it for
reference you know just for whenever I
need it and you're balling this year
and if the season ended today do you
feel like
I have a legitimate chance of winning a
Scion yeah I mean I think so I think
um last few starts haven't been like
great
um
yeah that's the thing so like the
seasons like you know it's you're just
trying to go on like runs and come as
long as they can
um but some other guys are pitching well
I mean it's now's you know Bond steel
Strider so like it's I think it's going
to come down to like a good race but
would you have a you you feel like
you've done well this year have a legit
chance but there is still a lot of
baseball to play and so knowing that
because it's always
I'll tell you when I won MVP that year
and I knew you know you hear all the
talks because we're watching baseball
shows and all those things and so
they're talking about us and we're
walking through the clubhouse and you
see yourself on the TV
and it was like you know the favor MVP
MVP favorite just any other whatever I
feel like it's harder to play it's it's
kind of harder to play from that
position than it is from like the middle
of the pack
going up if that makes sense you know
what I'm saying because yeah they game
plan to stop you so we got a game plan
different differently against you you
know what I'm saying and so how how is
it pitching with that like knowing and
because it'd be dope to win a Cy Young
like just winning Awards it's hard to
maintain the top the whole time so how
is your what how are you doing it yeah I
think
um
for me that that's kind of what I love
about it's like what excites me is like
I'm trying to
evolve whether it's every start every
month every year whatever it is
um I've just kind of talked to a lot of
guys that have played along pitched a
long time and like hey how did you stay
doing what you're doing and like you
have to continue to evolve so for me
it's kind of trying to figure out okay
what are teams trying to do to me what
like are they trying to eliminate a
pitch are they trying to Zone like
whatever it is so what does evolve mean
though because when you say evolve is
that
because what I'm hearing is you know
your game planning
is kind of floating you know depending
on kind of what's going on right
but evolve what does that mean so for me
it's more so I'm just it could mean
anything really it's like maybe adding a
pitch maybe tweaking a pitch maybe like
you're changing the shape of it maybe
you're moving changing pitch usage like
whatever that that might be like there's
basically just trying not to be the same
guy for a very long period of Time how
do you balance
changing a shape of a pitch or changing
or adding in a pitch when you've you're
already kind of first and you know
leading side young and now you start
tinkering them because you could start
tinkering with things and it goes
opposite way right this is true so how
do you oh I'm a tanker like I could like
if you see me in the field I'll play
catch for like it used to be like an
hour and then I have my like my elbow
had some inflammation a couple years ago
and the training stuff was like hey
that's this our catch play is not gonna
work no more you're gonna have to kind
of like you know shorten it whatever so
like I'm always like watching video and
don't get me wrong there's like even
beginning of the year when I felt like I
was I didn't feel great I was pitching
well and I was still on this like I'm
like something doesn't feel right
something to feel right so I'm always
trying to figure out like I always just
want to know like why things are going
the way they're going that way the next
time that comes up I want to be like
okay you know how to handle I could fix
it I like instead of this taking me six
weeks it's gonna take me six days or
whatever tinkering and changing are
different yeah sure so you're you're
more just tinkering yeah with to get the
shape back versus changing a grip or
changing I'm I'm trying to yeah it's
more it's more cues than anything I
rarely want to change
like a grip of anything it's just a
slight move nothing like totally on the
other side of the ball it's more
tinkering okay and going
you guys are good right and I think
for the most part everyone would say you
guys are good ahead of schedule
and
you are a very important piece of that
piece to that core bus corbs I said the
same exact thing
and and knowing that you guys are in a
playoff push right now
hot is that when you take the ball and
I'm curious from a pitcher's perspective
when you take the ball got a playoff
push we need to win I'm pitching well
for I so I want to pitch well for myself
right obviously for the Diamondbacks too
for myself playoff push all these things
how do you how does that make you feel
as a pitcher because you
kind of control the whole game yeah it's
uh
as cliche as it is the
trying to help team win do your job is
going to probably make the individual
stuff fall into place right so like
that's kind of where I'm at so there's
not necessarily like any added pressure
because when like the days on pitching
weather were 10 games under or 10 games
whatever it is like I'm trying to like I
want to win like I want us to win the
game so whether it's in a you know
obviously there's added pressure just
being in a playoff race it's just it is
what it is but it's natural yes but
that's so I'm not trying I don't really
try to let that consume me really it's
like I just have to go out and do my job
if I do my job it's like that's kind of
like the just the theme of like just the
team this is like everyone do your job
like if you do your job and rely on the
guy behind you to do his job
everything's gonna work out so are you a
a guy because to me there's kind of two
ways to think about it there's some guys
that they start thinking about winning
the game being for the team they play
better and then there's some guys that
think about themselves like I got to
take care of my job I got to go do this
I got to go hit this I got to go take
this many ground balls I gotta do this I
gotta the eye guys right but they help
the team too so which which one is your
perspective and neither one is wrong
neither one is wrong at all because at
the end of the day both both want to
help the team it's just two different
ways to think about it I would say I'm
I'm probably a little bit of both but if
I had to like break it down it's
probably more of like I like I have to I
gotta do what I have to do in the sense
of whatever it is I like I can can only
control what I'm gonna do right um but
there are some times why you know I just
certain like shutdown innings for
instance like I've been struggling doing
that it's like you know guys who scored
me a run or two and then I'll go and
give up a run or whatever it is so
that's something where I think about it
from more of a team perspective but from
the I would say for the most part it's
like okay I have to go out and get the
lead off hit her out or do whatever that
you know it is that that goal that I'm
setting for that inning to try and throw
up a zero okay so and let's get back to
Young Zack gallon
so it says here
you were drafted in the third round when
you were young by your dad yeah tell me
about that process yeah
um so I didn't want to play t-ball like
I was just like it like I don't want to
do that everybody ties or whatever you
get a dollar at the snack standings that
just didn't appeal to me like I was like
I'd rather just you know play real
baseball so my dad we live next door to
the commissioner my dad was like listen
I'm just gonna give him a uniform he's
taking my right field like just be a
part of the team he gets in a bat here
and there and were you good then or are
you just kind of no I was just I was
five but it was like seven eight nine
year old so there's no way okay yeah I
didn't get a hit until I was six so I
won a whole year of like me striking out
and my dad being like dang he dogged you
and then the next year when I was six I
I struck out first couple times he's
like that crimes that's five that's five
real stuff we're not doing it anymore so
then but yeah the commissioner was like
hey you're gonna have to draft them so
my dad apparently the story was my dad
came back to the house all mad and my
brother's like no this is gonna be great
he's like draft him in the third round
because if not you're gonna have to take
him in the first round next year because
they make you take your son like for
whatever first round he's like you're
gonna get another first round pick
you'll get to get another good player
um so yeah that's my dad kind of it's
stole me in the third round and we got
another kid
um this kid Danny baldino I think was
the first round pick next year was a
really good player oh yeah like it was
it kind of worked out my dad's like yeah
your brother was right he was smart
about that so yeah yeah how was it
playing for your dad
it was good
um but it was tough I mean it's tough at
the same time my dad like was big like
fundamentals
um and just like stressed that so
as a young kid like you're not really
you're just like I want to play like you
don't realize
um you know the building blocks that are
be being put in place but he was a good
coach like I mean I know like he would
always talk about like parents like they
wanted to play for my dad because he
practiced we practiced like two or three
times a week as opposed to some teams
were maybe in practice and once a week
like my dad was getting extra practices
so yeah it was it was great but like
he he now I look back like he was he
knew I could do a lot and expected a lot
of me but as a kid you don't realize
that you just think like your dad's like
you know whatever and just kind of like
breaking your balls but it's like now
your dad like knows it you can be good
and he's like seized the potential in
you does he still like uh he probably
didn't try and Coach you now but he that
he's still like all in locked in oh yeah
he's you know going yeah he's not going
to practice but he's he would if he if
he could yeah if he could oh yeah he I
mean he watches my star it's like three
or four times a year like he'll watch
him and then re-watch them and then in
the off season I'm like what are you
doing he's like I'm watching her start
again like which one he's like well I'm
at this start or whatever
um but yeah he'll throw some stuff in
there like does he ever give you any
good nuggets uh like something random
like you know what that's a that's a
because now your dad is more on the fan
perspective yeah because he's not in
the game yeah you got to be in the game
to really know the player perspective
right so not does he you know does he
ever give you like a that's a good
random nugget I'm trying to think so
like most recently he he he called me
and we were talking and he was asking
about
um my curveball which like
I felt okay about it's not like my
normal curveball it's just kind of
whatever and he's like you're not
throwing the same you know curveball
you're throwing like no I am it's just
not like sometimes you just grinding
like you know how it is like you just
like I don't have the feel
um he's just innocent but it probably
lets you know like oh it's not there
yeah and I I already knew that like it
was just like hey like I'm so I kind of
I was like no I'm like same thing like
you know we go through all and like I
mean yeah it's super instant he just
wants me to do well
um It's just sometimes I'm like
I for me I'm I kind of like I'm like hey
like I want you guys to be like the fan
I want you guys to enjoy this like I'll
handle like the baseball stuff and like
let me grind about it like you guys just
you know so it's good I mean but it's
it's all comes from a good place so I
can't get mad at it so growing up and
you you know you five
I guess
you graduate you how's the summer I mean
the winners and stuff there because
you guys don't get to play yeah you guys
don't get to play like so what do you do
yeah you you you you're just inside in
the gym taking ground ground balls yeah
you're right like indoors so I mean I
got super lucky
um
the travel team that I started playing
for they used to do it was like 13 18
they didn't have like literally they
didn't do young kids me and my buddies
were the first
11 year old team they did and they had
an indoor facility and then they moved
when we were 12 they moved into like
this badass one it was like huge you
could take ground balls full infield
whatever
um so you just kind of from November to
March you're like indoors like just do
you feel like that's a that's a
disadvantage
I think yes and no
um I think obviously you're not getting
the real reps on the field and you're
you're doing that but at the same time
there's this
at least for me one it was as a pitcher
like my parents shut me down I played
basketball and it was just like don't
pick up a ball is what it is I think you
save your arm because you see a lot of
these kids now playing all year oh my
God it's crazy and then at the same time
I there was this you always heard oh
well the kids from you know Florida
Georgia California playing 12 years
around they're 12 months around they're
you know more advanced than you and you
kind of get that in your head so it's
like Bill is this chip on your shoulder
two parts it kind of I said the same
thing you know being from Nashville
it was kind of Hit or Miss in the winter
time so we were inside and I hoped too
so to your point like I wasn't doing
anything you know with baseball and and
so when I got back out there I do I did
feel like I kind of was behind those
teams because those teams they they won
all the time and so yeah and you look
around in the league and a lot of guys
are from the Florida California Texas
thing but you know I to your point I
don't know how much of an advantage it
is so you hooped tell me about that like
you hooped all through high school no I
just played my uh just my freshman year
I played why'd you stop
so it got to the point where they were I
was a solid player but I wasn't like
gonna get crazy Varsity minutes so it
was like the
um coach was like listen you know anyone
who wants who's planning on making the
varsity team you have to play Summer
Ball you gotta play summer basketball
this was going in summer basketball okay
okay so I was like after my freshman
year like I was like okay like I'm I
don't know I would have got okay man
it's nothing crazy
um and I was I was small I was under
size like I didn't hit my growth spread
so I kind of saw the writing on the wall
I was like all right I'm gonna have to
give up baseball in the summertime and
I'm gonna like I said to add them five
five six I'm fresh so it's like I'm not
there's it's just like I had to look
myself in the mirror I'm like yeah this
is probably not it's not free yeah see I
I was too busy in the summertime I was
going to Hope too I was skipping the
baseball tournaments uh yeah for me at
baseball just like I was even like I
played football one year and oh you
played football too one year when I was
in like sixth grade so I was like and it
was what position is your place oh this
says my dad loves this story so I was
my dad before I go to football practice
he's like we're gonna have the tryouts
or whatever and my dad played my dad
coached like
youth football all like all grown up he
put on the line so he decides he's gonna
show me a three-point stance because my
brother went and he got in a track
stance tried to hit the sled it was the
whole thing so my dad showed me
I go to practice get in the three-point
stance and they're like look at this
great like uh I'm 75 pounds yeah I was
wondering dependence on the 105 team so
I just all I want to do is play with my
boys I played with baseball they were
playing on the B team they were all
getting to play wide receiver
quarterback whatever
and they decide they're gonna put me on
the a team and I'm 75 pounds on the 105
pound team our quarterback our running
back our tight end all like bigger than
me like I think this is like I think I
should probably be running the football
and they should be up front
um and yeah it was just like and I'm my
parents were like one sport at a time
there's no two sports
that was kind of like yeah I miss
baseball I don't think and that that
then you were just pretty all baseball
after your freshman year in high school
yeah it was all baseball after that so
and did you play any other positions in
high school I played a lot of shortstop
plus they play short
and pitched yeah so I probably played
more short in high school than I pitched
did you get you got drafted as a pitcher
yeah yeah played more short what about
during the summer summer I probably I
pitched a little bit more I played
second base but like pitched that was my
thing like in the summertime I was like
all right you're gonna pitching is
probably gonna be your your thing so but
in high school we had a good amount of
arms like Devin Smeltzer was on our team
too he was more of our Ace like our
number one guy he pitched and it was
like I played Short like my senior year
was the first time I threw regularly
like on a weekly basis other than that I
was like I would come in and throw a
relief or you know pitch like one we had
a big conference game or whatever
where'd you hit the lineup uh I think my
sophomore here like ninth and then
junior senior like first or second or
you could hit her I was okay like I
don't have any juice so I was trying to
steal singles in the doubles and stuff
like that like yeah there wasn't much
pop in there but I could pick it like I
could play I love taking ground balls
like BP you can yeah you can tell now oh
my God I don't care yeah I'm like I
would I'll take ground balls for an hour
what do are you sad that
you don't get to hit anymore no or were
you I was totally okay with that so my
only regret about it is that I don't
have a home run in the big lease that's
my only regret but my like they don't
pay me any more or less if I hit yeah
100 I hit 300 like it's the same thing I
tried to tell my dad my dad listen
they're not gonna pay me anymore or less
if I get a hit tonight or not it's like
so the only thing I could do is get hurt
okay so I like being able to just have
my pitch count throw to that let
somebody else who gets paid to hit hit
do their job so it's kind of so then you
go to UNC
right three years
and how was that how was UNC why did you
choose to go to UNC yeah so I I
my dad
had family from down there so he was the
first like Carolina
fan like in our family back in the 70s
um and then
my brother was a huge Michael Jordan fan
so I became a huge Michael Jordan fan he
went to Carolina
um and then like when I started taking
notice of college baseball they were
playing in Omaha seemed like every year
so I'm like I want to I want to do that
I want to play in Omaha it seems like
Carolina gets there every year so let's
let's go there
um so you like from a young kid like I
always wanted to go to Carolina oh that
the whole time you want to go since I
was like 10 or 11. it was like I want to
go to Carolina
um and yes and I got I got to go up
there once and I got the one of my uh
best friends brothers played on the JV
team in North Carolina so that's a super
dope campus it's unbelievable it's
amazing yeah so do you have any like
dope
stories or experiences that happened at
North Carolina or did you get to see
Michael Jordan did he come or you know
what I'm saying is anything like that
that kind of happened uh I'm trying to
think so I think he was there the one
year that the university went from Nike
to Jordan brand I think he was at the
game I don't remember if I was there
like if it was the year I was there or
the year after I left but there was
nothing crazy I remember my junior year
was the year we lost to Villanova in the
national championship so oh yeah just
kind of were you at the game no I was in
Chapel Hill like watching it like just
the vibe around the the town is awesome
because I mean basketball is like next
level there it's basketball and then
everything else is way down here so just
the vibe of being around that obviously
they didn't pull out to Victory but just
kind of being a part of that just seeing
what it's about and like what you know
this whole you know thing is it was
crazy so you're a Jordan guy I gotta ask
the question that everybody in America
asks
Jordan or LeBron Jordan
that was quick listen I as I've gotten
older I've if you'd asked me five years
ago I I wouldn't even entertain the
question okay but as I've gotten older I
do respect like what LeBron's done the
longevity of it that's kind of just like
but it's Jordan still Jordan yeah okay
so you got drafted by the Cardinals in
the third round again
was that that was that like kind of neat
like or ironic or anything did you think
about it yeah I mean I grew up a
Cardinals fan I was a huge Mark McGuire
guy when I was a kid
um I wore 25.
um
just like up until I was until we
switched towns and some other kid had 25
so I'm like I gotta pick a new number
now but I was a so for me it was like
it's what I dreamed of like all my life
I was like I'm gonna play in Bush
Stadium like that's what I want to do
like I'm gonna play for the Cardinals
and they get drafted by him yeah it was
just like it was insane and but then you
got traded and so
how did you feel when you got traded
like were you yeah that's your first
taste of hey this thing's a business
it's a business so
um yeah obviously super bummed
um just because I'm like all right
everything's working out
um got drafted by the car and I was
gonna play in the big lease for the car
on your childhood team that you're now
you're a fan of and then you know you
can trade and everything gets you know
turned upside down and like I said it's
you learn that it's a business fast and
it doesn't it doesn't matter like all
that stuff
um but yeah it was I think for me it was
I got to go to a place where
there was maybe some more opportunity uh
maybe some different voices and stuff
that you know maybe change the
trajectory in my career and
so you come and then you get here
got traded here
right because
the Marlins I don't did you debut with
the Marlins did you debuted you weren't
there long though I don't remember
the American League I didn't see you now
19 was my what was your what was your
first year in La 19 20 20 okay yeah so
19 was my first year with the Marlins
that's why I was up like two months I
think before I got traded and then you
got traded to the Diamondbacks and so
when you got traded to the Diamondbacks
you already knew it was a taste of of
the business so you weren't really
concerned with that I'm sure and you
went straight to the big leagues when
you got traded here yeah I thought I was
getting sent down when I got oh wow I
got called into office
um in the Mattingly's office and the
first like two minutes I blacked out I'm
like damn they're sending me down like
this sucks like I gotta go down AAA
whatever I'm pitching well and I'm like
I might as well tune back into this
conversation see what and then they were
like uh yeah we're gonna trade you but
they didn't tell me where so I was kind
of like oh that whole 10 minute
conversation I had to ask at the end
like all right so where am I going like
you're going to Arizona all right cool
so when you came out here
you're excited the team the team wasn't
that good at the time
now they were in a that team was in the
playoff what year was that 19. they were
like I wasn't here there's two games out
of the wild card so then you come in 20.
yeah 19 you pitched yeah 20. at what
point do you know like I'm staying like
this this is because the the right of
the wild card right you come in you help
that team and then
I'm not sure everything that was going
on so that's why I'm asking like
at what point did you know I'm here I
enjoy here we're gonna win here this
than the other yeah I'm saying I so
like you said I had no idea if I'm going
to stay in the big lease or what pitch
19 and just kind of the sentiment I've
got just from talking to like Mike Hayes
and our GM and and just some other
people around it's like you know we we
used some Capital to get you like this
is we didn't just get you to like be an
up down guy like we want you to be here
and be a part of this thing that we're
trying to build
um that help that help the mental yeah
for sure and like obviously playing well
helps too like so I played well this 15
starts or whatever I had so I felt
pretty good about going into 20 and they
were more so
like we we've been trying to get you
since May or whenever they were trying
so there was like there was respect and
being like we want you we want you here
so that was comforting um they kind of
gave me the
go to go into the off season and being
like okay I don't necessarily have a job
cemented but it's like my job to lose so
it kind of propelled me to be like all
right I'm gonna earn this thing take it
um
and yeah I mean we tried in 20 we went
out and got um we signed bomb Starling
Marte we traded for like just tried to
and then you know obviously everything
with the 20 years is crazy so yeah and
I'm sorry you I'm sure you could see
yourself staying you know where in
whatever opportunity you know for a long
time but being here being what what
would it mean to you if Arizona if you
were to stay with Arizona knowing that
this is kind of where you got your first
real opportunity yeah I'm always gonna
have like just crazy love for for
Arizona just because you know they they
they saw something in me that
maybe not a lot of other teams did
um and I think they treated me like a a
veteran with not much service that like
they they put a lot of trust in me so
like I have just a lot of respect for
them in that sense
um and yeah I mean just I said it this
past off season it's like this town in
terms of sports like
they deserve a winner like and you know
whether it's us it's the Suns like the
Cardinals like just hasn't like worked
out in the last you know how many ever
years so like but the fans are here like
they show up so it's like I want to you
know be a part of you know that the
pride people have in the city for you
know baseball team so you got you guys
are young right really young you got so
who who was kind of like the vet that
kind of runs it or or
is there one is it kind of like the
collective a collecting because I know
Longo is there and he's a vet you know
he's had he's got a lot of time
Christian Walker is there catel Marte
you know but
there's no real to me I don't see like a
real dominant or it seems like you guys
are all just a collective unit yes it uh
that's it's more collected that's a good
way to put it it's just kind of so you
had like
me Merrell Walker
um
Carson like guys like that kind of all
are in the same service time realm like
all kind of came up together like Meryl
and I
were like rookies even though Maryland
spent some time in Korea and like so
Tori was like Hey like I know you guys
are young but like I'm gonna treat you
guys like you're you've been here five
six seven years
um so like we all kind of had to learn
that as you know this thing has gone on
and just the stuff that we've gone
through in the last you know you know 20
21 and even 20 to beginning of 22. those
experiences have kind of you know aged
Us in the sense of like veterans but I
think that's kind of what makes our
clubhouse good is that
it was
like I said the guys I mentioned and
then you have the young guys come up
like Corbin Alec Thomas Jake McCarthy
those guys all grew up together in the
minor leagues and then there's no like
kind of separation between the young
guys the old guys like everyone just
wants to be boys and hang out and you
know have a good time
tell me this because I'll tell you my
perspective I want to hear what your
relationship with Tori what that means
to you and how that helps you because
for me I had Tori
and 14 15 I think he came over in either
Seven I think so I had him in 14 15 16.
and
at the time I think I was one of the
only rookies Jackie was there
but nobody else was there
that was you know my age you know kind
of
because I work I'm kind of the new wave
that kind of came through right you know
the Red Sox had just won the World
Series and so 13 and 13 and they were
terrible and 14 right
and so but Tori
Tori is the ones that single-handedly
kept me mentally sane at the field
because you know you've been you've seen
veterans especially losing it's just not
fun
nobody wants to lose and especially a
team that just won the World Series now
they're one of the worst teams in
baseball
everybody was salty
and I understood well I didn't at the
time but now I understand yeah yeah and
Tori having the relationship with Tori
like his openness is willing to
communicate his he knows when to push
you he knows when to back off he knows
when you need to chill he knows having
that relationship with him meant the
world to me and now he's your manager
and so I want to hear
that perspective you know like what that
means to you yeah it's huge I mean I
like I said he kind of he he had told me
and like when we were talking about the
Merrell thing like putting more
responsibility on me even as a young guy
was he told me he's like this is very
similar to what I did with you like
talking about like he was like this is
exactly what I did with mookie like he
was a young guy but I could see where he
was going and I won like we trusted him
with a lot more responsibility than
somebody like you know with a year
without however much service time he had
like as a young guy so for me I was like
okay to one be in the same conversation
as you at this point in time you'd
accomplished so much you'd won a World
Series you'd want MVP so like I'm like
all right cool that's like
and then at the same time he just like
you said he's a very good communicator
like I remember
there was a start like my third start
after I got traded here was in Colorado
and I hadn't pitching Colorado yet we're
in a playoff race and I'm like young kid
I'm trying to like do as much as I can
and after he takes Matt out to the
fourth inning I'm like I got 90 pitches
I'm like oh I'm good I'm good to go I
got at least another one I mean he's
like listen we're going to get to a
point in time
when I'm here and you're here and we're
gonna be able to have these
conversations where you know I'm
bouncing off you and all this stuff so
like he just from the get-go he was just
very trustworthy and at an open door and
I didn't I was expected it just to be
like the manager is going to tell you
exactly what they're going to do and you
just kind of have to abide by it but
like you know he's got to open to a
policy that I can come in and say like
we'll have like what he calls like
Chapel like I'll be like hey like we're
gonna go and like talk about something
that like whatever and yeah he's he's
awesome he's the best and I like it he
never really even though he was always
in the position of power he never like
flexed it you know it was understood but
you know he use he uses it
yeah Advantage yeah and he like he knows
like that see that's the thing like I
think a lot of some of the like really
good coaches don't get credit for is
that you have to learn how to manage
personalities that's really what you are
yeah that's what you're doing I mean
that's the thing like you have to it's
not like college where it's like you
could run it like a boot camp you could
run it like this is like you have to
manage personalities and like you said
no in the push buttons knowing to pull
off the Reigns like and he does a really
good job of that like feeling the pulse
and like he's the only I mean I've only
I've had two managers in the biglies but
when I got up here to see him come out
to BP and go to talk try to talk to
everybody everybody or a group of guys
like whatever throughout BP I was like
okay that's cool he's actually trying to
get to know and it's totally
non-baseball stuff it's he talks about
random stuff random stuff like just
trying to get to know like so and I
think that's cool that's something
that's like
you know I thought was different
so tell me about your
you like shoot do you do you like
clothes like I know you I know you like
wearing clothes right now
hey dude you naked and afraid you do
what you got to do just I do like that
show you know naked in afraid with some
J's on that's true all right we can make
that happen
so but do you spend money on clothes
like you like luxury Brands and those
things because based on I'm asking
because you're out your All-Star Game
outfit yeah that was outside of my
comfort that was oh you want to be
comfortable no I was I was I was good
but like that going crazy brand stuff
was that's not you it's not me but I'm
figuring I'm like okay
you know who knows how many times you
get to walk on a red car but All-Star
game I'm like let's just do like let's
just do something here so it's the Gucci
sweater is what's out of my comfort zone
like will I wear on the golf course you
know pants with a card shirt and then
like a crew or like a sweater over like
that's normal but to go for the brand
stuff that's that's what yeah that's a
little different what if it had like an
M for Marshalls
yeah listen I could have went and got a
Marsha's thing too you would have loved
that yeah I admittedly I haven't been to
a Marshalls in a while but like yeah I
just kind of was like I'm like let's
just do something like out of the
ordinary so and so
the one thing I do want to comment on
because I feel like
it sets the whole outfit off
is the hair or lack of you know and
you got a nice flow of hair and you cut
it it was longer right yeah it actually
just got cut I got like a trim yesterday
so how you how you keep your head is it
Head and Shoulders you know why you I
use uh whatever is usually at the field
like Head and Shoulders is like the
probably the the one that's normal uh so
I I look all curly and it's just
naturally curl like it's just natural
you just got a good headache and I just
put some like I forget what like just
it's like a conditioner cream whatever I
just put it in before I left and it just
like curls up so you don't even it's not
even like you're not the guy that gets
out of the shower puts wraps the towel
around them and then go stand in front
of the mirror and
I mean yeah I do that like to put this
stuff in my hair but like I'm not like I
was doing it like you know trying to
blow dry for a while my that's too much
maintenance like I just want to do that
that's not you I want your hips your
hair is just naturally just naturally
occurred nice yeah so who who this this
because corpse has a nice head of hair
too right he does
but he got the the mullet yeah
does his under because he always has a
hat on his mullet looked good it's all
like for me it's not my it's not my
style yeah I'm not sure it's anybody's
yeah yeah that's I mean and I've had a
couple people I've had some like fans
Heckle man they're like no it's mullet
I'm like it's not mullet like it's like
it's all it's it's not a mall like it is
what it is um what's crazy is core gonna
be like thanks yeah like so some dudes
like embrace it like chafing he's like
yeah he's great like you know so who
would you say give me like the top
three four guys the best hair in
baseball
best hair in baseball oh I don't know
yo yo y'all don't keep up with each
other like the best hair I've never been
in that conversation
I kind of like if you've never been in
the combo no the names I always see are
like India Vader he's got a nice head of
here
um
trying to think guys I have long hair
yeah I've never been in that
conversation which don't get me wrong 21
my hair was what about like Dansby
dansby's good hair too he's a good hair
girl yeah I was probably dance he's
probably got up there but yeah I've
always I've stopped keeping up because I
haven't been here that's not like a
thing that you feel like you could go I
mean you got four other days of nothing
so you might as well
make it look good on the fifth day and
then you just glistening and it's just
well that's what I did when the sweat
come down it's a little bit of
conditioner so that's so 21 obviously
you know covet not like couldn't really
get a haircut right and my uh so bad
like just my hair and 21 so now I've
gotten the point where I'm like I'm not
going out there with frizzy hair anymore
so I would I shower now before every
like start that's just like part of my
routine it's because I kind of like have
just that's my transition from getting
to the field to all right this is
starting my routine that you're gonna
pitch today because I you know I don't
want my hair to look you know like John
when I'm out there do you wear cologne
on uh on on your start day I don't know
I I had like a little cologne phase for
like a month
um but I always forget like put it on I
feel like I do I want to wear it because
I I you know you come we come in contact
with so many people and it's just a nice
accent just to smell nice and you know
I don't know if this is racist I'm gonna
say it's not racist but in the Latin
culture
always they always smell they smell they
smell the best yeah do you you shake
shake their hand you know get the little
you know the Bro hug yeah you smell like
it yes and now you smell good you know
and that it's always like it's never a
scent that's like man that's that's not
no it's like where you get that yeah
exactly it's always like it's it's crazy
I mean everyone talks about like uh
Machado being like you smell good I've
never
I don't think I've ever gotten a third
base when we played the Padres so I
never got to like yeah but like I know
the guys that we have in our clubhouse
are like always got something so it's
like yeah that I don't know what's magic
or some secret whatever they got so I
don't know do you wear cologne outside
of the field
same thing I gotta try to but like I
just forget like I mean yeah it's like I
so my girlfriend got me for
um
Valentine's Day or whatever like some
cologne in there some armor some of my
cologne thing that lasted like a month
or two and then I'm like no I forgot
like yeah it's just yeah it's bad okay
bro so have you ever done an Immaculate
grid yeah
are you good uh in terms of like I try
and go for like the super low Rarity
score which maybe like I don't know I
think I could do it like if it was just
like not just like normal names
really terrible I haven't done my one
yet yeah we did it yesterday and
[Music]
we wasted time not good no so do you
want to do one yeah let's do it let's
see what we got let's see what we got is
this for today this is
for today yeah yep so Pittsburgh and
Yankees it that would be I Know Rich
Hill
Rich Hill works I was gonna say clay
Holmes too or clay Holmes yep
that works see I like that one percent
that I guess the so I've looked at this
now that means like that's good that's
super rare like a lot of people are
getting oh wow so some people from what
it sounds like I've seen like The
Barstow guys or whoever like the John
Boy guys they try to get the slowest
percentage like added up
you know what I mean so like see how it
like says like one percent there at the
end you'll get this thing it's like a
rarity score and that'll say like how
rare your grid was like of thinking of
names that people aren't gonna think of
as opposed to going like
you know somebody Super Famous like it's
trying to get like a unique Grid in
there like we just I don't know what you
do I'm just uh
so we're just gonna keep on going
because I'm confused so
Sam frannen in the Yankees you know
anybody
um
um San Fran and the Yankees not that I
could think out on the top of my head
that's that's there if you like rare
stuff there you go yeah that's rare yeah
that's gonna be uh
oh I'm trying to think a Yankee that was
Rookie of the Year you know that I mean
I'm gonna be judged I would yeah
has to be but see I would go with like
for me yeah judge is good but like see
how it says 44 that means everybody got
him I would try and think of one that
was like
oh so you're like it's the overachiever
thing kind of yeah
got it guys like even if I think I'm
just trying to fill it out exactly yeah
yeah I just I was cool like in school I
was cool with just taking I ain't wanna
see
but if I'm a Odyssey I was like you know
what it is what it is I'm a masochist so
I try to put myself through like a grind
here and just be like all right like oh
it was crazy name could I think I'm not
a big I I have to grind and I you know
you learn to enjoy grinding but I'm not
gonna grind off yeah but you know you
gotta do what you got to do Pittsburgh
and the twins
oh
uh I think probably Rachel could
probably fill in on that I want to get
two I don't know did he pitch for the
twins I don't know I feel like Rachel's
played for a lot of teams he's played
for a lot of teams I don't know that
he's played for the twins uh I mean I
would say like Roberto Clement did he he
had to have won a gold glove right did
they have a gold glove back then
I don't know
like when the gold gloves start
hello there you go there it goes 31 that
means I'm that that's not good it's
solid I mean it's good for me though
yeah I mean I don't think I would have
come up with anybody else like I you
know I mean so like Brandon Crawford
yeah uh no we you want to go more rare
no that's we're gonna go for just
filling it in okay did you and corbs get
all nine no all right then we're going
for just a perfect group we've already
we've already
we've already beat me and corbs yeah
we're all right we're going with that
um I don't know any I don't know anybody
that's played for the twins
and rookie of the year I mean Joe Mauer
yeah you try that there you go Joe
Maurer I would think
wow
Ed on the twins like this I mean like
did Kirby Puckett win a rookie of the
year I don't even know that's what I'm
saying like uh Justin Moore know
um you like more now we only got well
we're not gonna be able to get a perfect
one yeah
yeah
that's tough I'm blaming this one on you
are you trying to go too too rare oh I
want to be here well we both went with
Joe Maurer and that didn't work
[Laughter]
all right so
um let's see a gold glove and a rookie
of the year
let's see if we know that one
I don't even know
Rookie of the Year Gold Glove and I
don't even know rookies rookies of the
year like I mean
um
I mean when you go back you talk to
corpse
you can't really tell them use that much
better because you only got one I mean
yeah that's true what how many did you
guys get three
and you going there for oh we got three
guesses left though
okay I mean I don't know him and this is
when I would just try and just shut it
down just be like I'm done yeah I mean
because I do crossword puzzles and when
I don't know the crossword puzzle and I
get into now I have to expand into
other stuff I can't do that I mean yeah
I would I got yeah I'm the one like I
would have to I would have to finish it
come on let's do it all right let's do
it so but I mean we could be here for
who knows how long well we got a couple
more minutes all right let's see what we
got rookie I just don't know like nine
years the problem is I'm expanding in
the twins history I have no idea with
that
yeah I'm trying to think like the Twins
and I I don't even know
you know I guess I'm with the doctor you
know with the Dodgers you think I know
something about San Fran but I don't
yeah I don't the same friend in the
Yankees
I'm trying to like you call this road on
oh there you go
21 that's not two more of them
all right all right so again let's see
yeah Pirates and Twins and stuff I I
don't know the Pirates and yeah no no I
don't know Sam for handling twins like
it just seems like the twins in San Fran
don't go to like if you were played with
San Fran you probably ain't about to
sign with the twins you probably didn't
but but somebody must have somebody must
have somebody must have somebody did it
who what was the reliever's name I think
there was a reliever
um
oh Romo yeah uh Sergio Romo yeah yeah
that's a good one
yeah yeah the the the same friend damn
always I play with Sergio I don't even
think about that that's 10 there you go
that's good reliever but I was thinking
another reliever for Pittsburgh and the
twins uh that wasn't even the one he was
talking about no it wasn't so I'm not
gonna take Rodriguez like Rodriguez
I don't don't put that down I don't know
I don't I a gold glove in the Rookie of
the Year that's what's throwing me up
because I don't even know who the Rookie
of the years were and you that means
you've won the gold glove in the same
year too right so like who's oh did
Arenado win a rookie of the year I don't
know I don't know who's won Rookie of
the Year I had no idea
are you uh are you on this did you win
rookie there wasn't eligible for Rookie
of the Year
we have talked about him in the show
oh
pujos Arenado
oh my God Maguire won a gold glove
they was just giving them out if he want
to go below
he want to go that's crazy look at that
Rarity score yeah 0.5 yeah there you go
that's what makes that gallon happen
that damn that's tough I mean I didn't
know McGuire wanted I would have never
in my life guessed he won a Gold Club me
neither you know and that's did Aaron
Otto win Rookie of the Year sorry sorry
Mark
because that would work to Aaron
whenever it's gold glove I go there and
now my guys won like 100 of them yeah
so let's get to some fan questions bro
all right let's do it
um
how did you feel I got a fan they said
how did you feel when how does it feel
to strike out Otani I mean it's probably
just a strikeout I would assume but
you know expect let's go with this how
would it feel if otani's up it's second
and third two outs and you need this
it's uh I guess it would be the
or the top of the fifth bottom and fifth
whatever
with with two outs you need this out for
a
uh what's it when you go six six innings
in quality Star Quality star you need
this for a quality to start but you also
need it for a dub for the boys like and
you punched him out what would you do
yeah I mean I
probably it's not even just about him
this is just about more about the spot
but yeah I mean it's it's he's
unbelievable I mean it's uh there's not
there's not many holes in his in his
swing spots to go
um you gotta you know pick your spots
where you're gonna
you know challenge not challenge
whatever it is
um so yeah I mean it was it's crazy to
punch him out especially I mean you know
how it was every chain and his name like
or Chan coming to Seattle so yeah I was
like man it's so nice a chance for me to
come to Seattle that's that's awesome
um so yeah I was just like man if I if
he gets me right here I'm like this
place is going to go and it's gonna be
everywhere
um so that's that's shout out to Sean
Murphy because I probably would have
threw him a 3-2 heater just because it's
All-Star game like whatever he called
the curveball if you threw a 3-2 heater
he would hit it 700 feet oh my gosh yeah
like that it would it would have one
thousand percent yeah unless I mean if I
miss if it was a ball I could walk yeah
but if it was in a strike zone he might
have hit him yeah yeah to the Pacific
Ocean I don't know it was like yeah do
you um
I'm sure I'm sure you do but like how
much do you appreciate like kind of what
he is doing it's not I mean it's crazy
it's like
I mean I get like you know Babe Ruth did
what he did but like
this doesn't this is unbelievable
compared to Babe Ruth and it's like it's
funny to hear people be like not that I
ever saw baby play but like just from
the game of back then to now like to
people even put in the same conversation
it's like it's it's not even close
they're just he's one of those guys that
when you're done playing like I'll be
like I played against ohtani play
against the greatest player that we've
maybe I think we don't appreciate it
while we're playing you know I we do to
a certain degree but like we don't also
because we I think we get numb to it
yeah you're like okay like it's on MLB
Network you're like this guy's on there
again you're like but like he's throwing
100 and hitting balls 500. the thing
that I always get to like the picture
part of it because like I know how hard
hitting is but I don't at the same time
like you know how heart pitching is I
know how hard pitching is and that like
he just is gonna he's gonna SWAT
55 60 homers this year but then he's
also throws a hundred like that's the
that's the part that fires me up like
this guy's throwing a hundred like how
many guys throw 100 in the big leagues
yeah I mean now a lot but not not they
don't hit 50 60 yeah they're like I mean
that's the thing it's like this guy is
gonna it's it's fascinating really so if
you had one matchup right one guy you
like you know what I want to see what
it's like to face him
who would it be me I'm facing them yeah
in any part of like history I guess
um
probably Babe Ruth Babe Ruth I just want
to see yeah because I'll talk a lot of
and I'll be like baby's good he
would have oh 50 today like just and I
get I mean it's gonna be the way it is
like one world two people I'm like you
guys couldn't play like now so it's just
one of those things but yeah I just you
know I want to see like was it legit or
was it like yeah I don't know if I was a
picture no disrespectful but like I just
want to know you want to see it yeah I
just want to see if I was a pitcher
I I would want to see I want to face
Barry Bonds to see what it's really
that's another good one really like like
you're telling me I can't throw one
pitch in the strike zone not one
I love hearing stories about Barry Bonds
like so Mike Fetters is our Bullpen
coach
I'm not sure if you play with Barry or
just like was friend zone because they
play at the same time and he he would
always just be like Barry got one pitch
a night and he never missed that's what
I'm saying he never missed you're
telling me I can't throw one pitch and
it's automatic homework
the fact that they've walked him where
the base is loaded is just like it's
fascinating to me yeah that's bear is
another good one like but I I that I've
seen enough clips and like enough as a
kid like kind of grasp how good he was
um yeah babe the you would never yeah
you just never know but yeah Barry I
mean it's and I just talking to guys
like Steven vote so he's from like that
area and he's like watching going to the
game and watching Barry Bonds hit he was
like it was a sight to see he's like so
every three Innings the whole entire
Stadium would get up on their feet
because you know watch him like he was
like it was unbelievable okay so one
more question bro would you rather be
forced to sing along or dance or dance
to every song You Hear would you rather
sing along with every song you hear or
dance to every song You Hear sing like
Yeah Yeah dance would be I'm Alan I'm
out on dancing like I mean at a like at
a wedding could I
okay I'm not gonna make a fool of myself
but the singing I like at some point I
probably will make a fool of myself
dancing so singing I think I could keep
it at least tempered to the point where
it's like whatever so if you're going
when you go to the wedding right and
this is going to tell me a lot about you
you go to a wedding whatever you get out
there it's time to dance are you just
the guy that does the simple two-step
uh yeah probably I mean it depends I
mean it depends if the drinks are
flowing maybe like who knows like maybe
like but yeah for the most part
um I'm trying not to draw a lot of
attention to myself uh in situations
like that but you know you never know
what gets in you if the The Vibes are
high but yeah for the most part I'm
I'm pretty pretty I see you with the
drink flow the drinks flowing you know
hair just you know shining off the
whatever but the only thing that what
sucks is like you know typically the
guys pull their tie off and you know
it's time to run your neck yours would
be clip on though man because they don't
sell ties like that at Marshall that's
true so you just gotta actually no I've
gotten some ties at Marshalls and they
tie yeah you don't have to clip it
around your head that you would never
see me doing that oh you wouldn't even
if it was a tide tie whatever I'm not
tying around my head no no I'd take the
tie off maybe and leave but I'm not
tying around my head so you won't get
that Lit No actually that's the thing
where you're drawing attention to
yourself okay it's like well you know I
had to ask yeah no I'm not I'm not
trying to you know you're not making a
fool for yourself yeah you know what I
mean well thanks for coming on the show
man you know um
I've seen you a couple times you know
especially when I went out to eat or
when I went to grab some food I saw you
and your girl and uh you know we talked
for a second and I could tell you it's
super personal and just a genuine good
dude and I wish you all the success in
the world you know we got a long time
playing against each other
um and so you know I'm sure there'll be
many good battles absolutely thank you I
want to give you a shout out thank you
for um
let me hit my first Dodger homework
I'll never forget it and the only foot
changes the only reason why I remember
the Homer is because the pitch I hit I
had no business swinging it no business
swinging no business swinging and I I
don't know how I hit it when I hit it I
think I was I was running around the
bases like what just happened I so yeah
I remember Thrones like man that's a
pretty good pitch and you're the Home
Run I said
after like there was a lot of guys
watching like I need to see that again
how do you do that I'm like you just
like pulled your hands in I don't know
like I don't know it's like I think
that's probably how I see it out of your
hand like it it's I see it horrible I'll
swing it over I just was like this is
the biggest it's like I'm like this like
yeah it was uh I was like I thought that
was a pretty good pitch but uh you
you've seen what you do in the big
leagues dog but uh just keep on going
man keep on uh setting the example for
the guys you know you like I told Corbin
yesterday you him
all you guys but especially like you and
him the main guys that are out there
producing each and every time they're on
the field like y'all gonna be important
bro and it's important to just embrace
it and know that
you got to perform absolutely especially
going down for this Cy Young race like
I'm not adding pressure bro I'm just
giving you I like see this thing I like
that I like the added pressure though
like I would go I would rather be like
is this like the same thing like with
the streak like I'm like all right I'm
gonna I gotta go out and earn this thing
like there was lineups that I had to
face in my eyes oh your scoreless streak
yeah that's not gonna be like an easy
line how many innings was it again
44. yeah there you go I had to go to
Colorado like they're always like I'm
like I love this like I want to go out
and earn like if I did it I earned it
like this like I don't want anyone to
just
hand it to me I want to take it so yeah
I gotta love the pressure it's like
almost like just a little extra
motivation yeah good when's your
birthday bro uh August 3rd
oh you just it just it's like last week
yeah yeah so
before we rap guys
if you miss Zach's birthday he would
love TJ Maxx Marshalls any of those gift
cards sent to his locker attention Zach
gallon Diamondback Chase Field
um just it you can find it on Google or
whatever Chase Field and so Zach be
ready bro you're about to get some gift
card what I probably do is I would
probably donate them to you know help
somebody get some some clothes all right
well you got to get you some clothes but
please don't stand up if you don't like
really don't understand but if you do I
will donate them I won't use them for
myself so make sure you send one that is
only for Zach because he he only got
clip on top you know what I'm saying the
big looks so anyways we'll catch you
guys next time on on base
[Music]
thank you